bootle cat podcast special guest in here
representing Victorville I've never said
that before
janaya's here welcome thank you for
having me so were you like born and
raised in Victorville yes what's that
like
um
it's it's it very desolate out there
very boring it's it's interesting
there's a lot of like just illegal trap
houses and weed grows out there yes
that's where everybody they leave LA and
then they go to Victorville or Apple
Valley and then they grow tons of drugs
in their backyard yes a lot of abandoned
houses yes yes I know way too much about
Victorville and uh I'd be in Apple
Valley a lot I actually have a
Victorville story
I broke down driving from Vegas to pay
dues Festival do you know what that is
no no okay so maybe like 10 years ago
there was this Festival that MERS used
to throw called Paid Dues it was like a
rolling what's not rolling loud it was
like rock do you remember Rock the bells
at all
it's before your era okay
anyway I had like I don't know 60
tickets to this thing that I stole from
my promotions director at the radio
station in Vegas right so I'm like all
right we got to go to [__] it was at
uh in San Bernardino
and I had all this all these tickets I
was like I gotta go out there and sell
them I'm gonna scalp these [__]
tickets you know we broke down in the
middle of the desert oh
me and my best friend David hitchhiked
with some drunk ass fools who were
drinking and driving like a 24 pack of
Bud Light the whole time no
we stop in Apple Valley at like the
craziest trap house I've ever seen in my
life I'm thinking these guys are gonna
kill us and harvest our organs
not Harvester orchids it was wild we're
like texting people like yo bro we're in
some place called Apple Valley never
been oh no I know you were scared it was
just wild it was like I didn't like I
still haven't seen this part of Apple
Valley I was in because it was [__] up
like there was like a park like a horror
movie basically yeah and then we ended
up in Victorville and then finally we
got dropped off in San Bernardino but
that was my first impression of of your
city but I've been back a lot more so
cool down I mean I hope I can make a
better impression than that for
Victorville do you guys like do like as
a kid do you grow up like coming to La
for stuff or because it's kind of far I
honestly had never been to like La
really yeah my whole life I was really
in just Victorville that was it so what
like when you're growing up like are you
singing the whole time yes yes that that
was all I had right you know I had a big
imagination being somewhere where
there's not a lot going on like out here
there's so much going on but when you're
in a town that's just so desolate and
there's really nothing all you have is
your imagination and your talents to
just kind of distract you what was uh
for you like the moment where you
started to catch some sort of traction
because obviously you're signed a Def
Jam that's a big deal
how would I it took me it took me a
while I started my Tick Tock when I was
17 18 and I was just posting covers on
there really right it took a while for
people to give me attention it took
about 30 40 videos until I like hit a
big video oh wow yeah
um you gotta be consistent yeah
interesting yeah it was very frustrating
because Tick Tock like you just never
know with it so that was a thing for me
but around 2019 2020 is when I really
started to gain traction with just my
covers so the covers are what did like
people just heard you what do you
remember what song you covered that was
like the one that really I would say the
first one was one plus one by Beyonce
okay and then the second one was
nobody's supposed to be here by Deborah
Cox oh you got the the jams yep so for
you like uh because I feel like a lot of
people
they'll go on Tick Tock or they'll go on
like the maybe it's YouTube or reels or
whatever and they get like super
deflated or dis discouraged when like
the first like 10 videos don't work and
then they kind of give up like for you
it was it just like no matter what
you're gonna just got nothing to lose
really I have nothing to lose in the
desert hanging out I was working at
Walmart at the time like oh yeah almost
cashier
yeah so that was motivating in
Victorville Walmart in Victorville that
was motivation enough like I had nothing
to lose you had to have seen some [__]
is this a 24-hour Walmart yes this was
24 hours this was like and this was Mike
it's my favorite yeah when people are
going crazy and taking all the time in
the middle at Victorville yes
what kind of wild ass [__] did you see
we got oh you're not gonna believe me we
got we almost got robbed by somebody
um oh I believe you in a wheelchair
were they overweight
I don't exactly remember the specifics
of it but we almost got robbed by
somebody that was in a wheelchair um and
that was
that was crazy
um cargo shorts on and cargo yeah it was
it was America I don't even know how
that you know Bald Eagle t-shirt and a
mega hat yeah and they're like give me
all your give me all your Marlboro Reds
I
foreign
that happened um let's go Brandon
they had me doing crazy stuff like I was
the cashier but they had me plan
security sometimes because people would
try and steal like the groceries and
their whatever it is and they're like go
stand out front and make sure they don't
leave and I'm like I'm not did you work
overnight yes oh wow yes good for you
yes I used to just go and get super high
with my friends and hang out at Walmart
when I was like 15 because it was the
only thing near our house
like the [__] you see at three in the
morning or Walmart's wild no especially
out there because like particular area
there is nothing to do so all you do is
go to Walmart and you know see weird
stuff happening yeah like I'm sure like
yeah are you like pretty hip to the fact
there's like all the weed grows in the
world are around your house yes yeah yes
it's pretty crazy it is pretty crazy
yeah yeah it's kind of wild like uh and
then my like I go out there a lot
because my friend has a ranch and like a
will like drive his uh what are those
the Can-Ams like the four wheelers just
in the middle of Apple Valley oh my gosh
yeah that's like the culture that is the
main yes that is the culture out there
so surprised that you wow it's great
that you know all this oh
you have to like explain it too much oh
I'm hip yeah there's like yeah I mean
I've spent a lot of Memorial Day
weekends out there and then we'll go to
like yeah everything's just so sad like
I'll go to like a stator Bros out there
or whatever it is oh no it's just a
terrible grocery store you're going to
Stater Brothers yeah it's a bad plan no
no good yard sales in Apple Valley yeah
yeah yeah a lot of old folks and drug
dealers that's about it yes it's either
really old people or really old drug
addicts or drugs yes that's the best way
to explain it yo what up it's bootleg
cab we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our folks at my bookie that's
right so many ways you can gamble with
my bookie right now man of course you
got NBA playoffs Western Conference
Finals Eastern Conference Finals they're
set I love Celtics versus Lakers in the
finals all right you can sign up at
mybookie.ag right now using that promo
code bootleg and get a very generous
first deposit bonus that's right and
they just got the craziest like revamp
of the online casino it's like a Las
Vegas experience if you play cards
Blackjack roulette uh you shoot dice
whatever it is they have like live
dealers handling it for you wherever
you're at you could be at the airport
and be playing [__] roulette on your
phone it's amazing mybookie.ag sign up
with that promo code bootleg right now
you can bet on Sports you can do slots
you can do Blackjack uh craps whatever
you're into mybookie.ag promo code
bootleg for that first deposit bonus and
it is a generous one also gotta give a
shout out to our family at King Palms
shout out to King Palm man if you only
know about King Palms you're our new
sponsor on the bootleg kept podcast and
they got such a great product the best
thing about King Palms is it's all
organic man no tobacco in these wraps
they're straight Leafs and the best
thing uh about them is they got this
product
their flavor terpene tips all right you
stuff them with your with your product
do we got one here oh we do got one here
all right we have one right here we got
one right here all right you stuff this
with your uh premium cannabis from Hardy
in Las Vegas
all right you smoke up pinch that tip
you're gonna get a burst of flavor yeah
this is the energy drink flavor we got
Peach pineapple we got watermelon wave
also don't forget the goddamn
blue grapes you know what I mean and
also this is a tobacco-free wrap it's
totally organic it's literally a leaf
let me show you what I mean
that is just a big ass Leaf guys all
right so what you could do is go to
kingpom.com weeds flying everywhere
kingpop.com promo code bootleg and uh
you can get 50 off of whatever you order
at kingpom.com and don't forget to check
them out because they're everywhere your
local smoke shop your local liquor store
7-Eleven smoke the King Palm all right
it's organic it ain't like all that
other [__] y'all be [__] stuffing
in your lungs man all right shout out to
kingpong kingpom.com promo code bootleg
right now and it's actually promo code
bootleg Kev
half off everything let's get back to
the interview who would you uh kind of
like say are your biggest influences as
an artist
I would say number one I would say
prince and I say prince yes Prince shout
out to Prince shout out to Prince
um that was the first
piece of art that I listened to when I
was a kid that was like my Awakening
where I realized I wanted to do music
the first movie I ever saw was purple
rain and I remember the first movie you
ever saw in life Purple Rain it was was
purple or at least the first Disney
movies the first movie that I remember
okay
over there I was just really
um mesmerized by how he didn't care
right like what he was doing for back
then to be wearing what he was wearing
and singing the way he was singing and
riding the way yeah it was just I was
like who is that so I would say number
one is Prince number two would be
Beyonce
I mean that's a good one-two Punch Yeah
Beyonce I mean just her work ethic in
general her just everything about her
all right have you sold any organs to
get Beyonce tickets yet no no not yet
but I'm playing
yeah because
there's people I know who are going to
Europe just to see the tour because it's
like it's not even doesn't make sense to
go here because it's so expensive it's
so expensive yeah but I gotta do it have
you seen her live no oh I haven't seen
her live yet but I'm going to the
Renaissance concert you watch the
Netflix the little like uh the Coachella
performance over and over it is good
over and over again yeah shout out to
Beyonce so you take Prince over Michael
Jackson
I wouldn't necessarily say that I
wouldn't say that Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson
for different reasons like he was Prince
is like an alien like talented human
being yes they're both very very
talented I would just say I leaned
towards more towards Prince growing up
shout out to uh what's your favorite
Beyonce album
oh that is so hard for okay before
shout out to Beyonce Beyonce got
Classics I would say four and then
lemonade after
Lemonade's the one where it was like
right after uh the breakup right or is
that the elevator incident right yeah oh
my God
yeah I think it wasn't lemonade the one
that just came out out of nowhere
it was like one day we woke up and the
album was out I think I think so I'm
pretty sure or or no I feel like maybe
she's done that more than once maybe I'm
tripping yeah she did that more than
once it was with that one and then her
self-titled
um album so you've been putting out a
lot of dope uh like visuals that
everything's black and white why is
everything black and white
everything in it everything is black and
white because growing up out in
Victorville where there's really nothing
and there's nothing going on that's how
I saw the world black and white it
wasn't until
I started going other places like coming
out to LA and doing music and seeing the
culture and just going different places
that I felt like I started to see in
color right really really really hard to
like I told you
have an imagination out there for sure I
don't think people understand it is no
it really is you come out here and it's
you know you just see everything or even
like you're kind of in the middle
between Vegas and L.A did you go to
Vegas a lot as a kid no no no yeah my
parents were my mom was very strict
growing up so like I I really didn't I
really didn't go anywhere did you watch
The Simpsons were you allowed to watch
The Simpsons oh yeah I don't know how
strict there's some moms who didn't let
like my friends Watch The Simpsons or
family-wise of course everybody's
watched The Simpsons yeah that's good I
don't know I got friends who grew up
like super strict religious households
when we were over there couldn't watch
The Simpsons Watch The Simpsons
can celebrate Halloween you know oh it's
like the devil's holiday you know oh God
we won't get into that so everything's
black and white because you feel like
being from where you're from that was
kind of like
it's probably how a lot of people see
the world right yeah it's how a lot of
people see the world but when you have a
big dream a lot of people are going to
think you're crazy right they see things
in black and white and that's how I see
it that's why I never get mad at people
because your environment where you're at
of course when somebody tells you I want
to be I want to be a big artist they're
going to be like oh that's not you know
that's not going to happen that's why I
say like I wanted to give my audience a
point of view from how I saw things and
I felt like in my city
a lot of things were black and white
yeah has there been any uh Like Rappers
or anybody from out there that's popped
off I feel like I feel like I've ever
I'd have heard of somebody if there have
I don't think they claim Victorville I
usually hear them say that they're from
LA
that's a crazy statement yeah
that [__] is up a hill usually they say
that they're familiar you gotta drive up
a mountain to get there yes you do so
it's very interesting but it's all right
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at Blue chew
baby that's right it's getting hot
outside you know what that means fellas
you're about to go get that dick wet you
know what I'm saying it might as well be
really hard it might as well be as hard
as it could possibly be and with
Bluetooth you will achieve such hardness
all right it's seriously amazing uh and
the best part about Bluetooth is you can
find out if it works don't just take my
word for it they're going to give you a
month's supply for free go to
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get a month supply for free
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg now
it's the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis minus the awkward
doctor appointment you do not have to go
see some old dude and tell them about
your erectile dysfunction issues in
person because that's a [__] awkward
conversation bruh all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com right now use the
promo code bootleg they're going to get
you hooked up with a month of supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars in
shipping no awkward doctor's
appointments same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis plus they got the
Bluetooth mint it's a chewable it's
great tastes like mint it's also the
same active ingredient as Levitra so
summertime's coming fellas you don't
want to underperform make sure your dick
is rocked up baby all right go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
hey man it works what do you want from
me it [__] works everyone should have
a little Bluetooth in case of an
emergency
you might have an emergency you need to
pop a Bluetooth to it it's a chewable
you know what I mean anyway also got a
shout out to our family at Odd Socks
don't forget go to oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg say 20 off man they
got the underwear that they just dropped
uh last year that's amazing so not only
do you get the most comfortable socks in
the world but you can also get the most
comfortable withdrawals in the world all
the crazy licenses they gotta have baked
socks they just announced their Hasbro
collection which is crazy because that
means you're going to get Monopoly socks
Transformer socks Power Ranger socks so
much [__] going with Odd Socks plus they
got The Odd Socks Basics my favorite
this is why I wear every day I wear the
basics because they're the most
comfortable socks I've ever put on my
[__] feet so experience the most
comfortable socks in the world with me
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off shout out to Odd Socks let's
get back to the interview have you ever
gone the back way and there's like that
airplane graveyard looking yes you're
talking about George it's the George Air
Base yeah I just know I took the back
way to Vegas once and it had me drive
literally through Victorville like
through the streets and I was just like
I looked over to the left and there's
like all these [__] airplanes in the
middle of the desert George Air Base
have you ever seen the abandoned homes
next to it that was the whole that was
the old Air Base yeah I just thought
they say it's haunted this [__] is wild
out here bro people live out here bro
yes like people are from there and live
out there shit's crazy it's like hills
have eyes out there yeah that's actually
a perfect comparison heels have eyes
yeah well shout out to you for uh for
doing your thing uh obviously you have
songs out is there going to be body of
work come in what's what's tell me
what's on the way yes so the whole tape
is coming literally next month and right
now I'm working on my second tape so
we're calling these mixtapes yes they're
mixtapes okay a new single called false
prophet is coming out this week this
Friday okay the 19th why false prophet
oh it's such a long story well when I
was growing up
um
my mom and I we were we were in a very I
would say abusive household and my dad
um at the time decided he wanted to be a
pastor oh [__] so kind of what you were
saying with those strict parents that
wouldn't let their kids well he just
decided one day he just decided that he
was going to do it and
you know he wasn't he wasn't he didn't
go about it in a very Godly way was it
culti no it wasn't colty it was more so
that he was getting up on stage
preaching to a congregation but would go
home and it would be another thing oh
wow so the fact that happens a lot it no
it does happen a lot more than people
you know talk about but he would go on
stage and you know preach and say the
word and whatnot but we would go home
and it was it was a completely different
story wow so that that's where I got the
title false prophet from so it's about
your dad kind of yes yes wow
so you grew up religion religious ish
kind of yeah yeah I mean you obviously
were going to church on on the weekends
yeah I was going to church every Sunday
and I mean I'm still you know I have my
faith and whatnot but at the time it was
it was very complicated right that
should probably make you like resent
Church no no no it has nothing to do
with the church or or God or anything in
general I think
I separate that
I'm really good at separating it yeah
the I think that the only time like I
grew up like really like going to church
was Channel 21 in Phoenix Arizona you'd
be able to turn it on and there'd be
those Turnt Up dudes on TV with them
suits man you know what I mean they'd
just be barking and like bruh I want to
hang out with this pip looking preach
preacher guy yeah I mean a lot of these
preachers they're like they're dressed
like you know like yeah like Steve
Harvey and like kings of comedy you know
yeah yeah well look uh false prophet
coming out soon mixtape come and win
mixtape is coming next month next month
and you're already working on the new
yes new tape the new tape yes uh would
you say you have any hip-hop influence
with doing the mixtape route because
that's kind of like a rapper thing to do
you know yeah yeah I would definitely
say I have a lot of um hip-hop influence
behind that who's your favorite rapper
oh that is such a hard question jeez my
favorite rapper
I would have to say Eric Sermon
wow Eric's sermon I'd say Eric Sermon
and then today I'd say Drake because he
you know he's able to do r b he's able
to do rap he's able to do dancehall
where were you listening to Eric's
Terminator I actually just met him a
couple how many months ago did I meet
him two I met him about two months ago
is he your favorite rapper because you
just met him and you're like no because
he's he's no no no no no no no no he's
just he's he's legendary so you were
listening to like EPMD or were you
listening to like Just Like Music
yeah okay
no I do I do I do but he's he's such a
he's such a dope guy
shout out to him shout out to him and he
has green eyes
yes he does he's a legend that's wild I
didn't expect you to say Eric Sherman no
I've ever I respect him he's a really
dope guy all right we'll go get the uh
the the tape when it drops you have a
name for it yes it the name is 4 P.M in
the bill
Victorville
Victorville short Bill love it not
dreamville Victorville I like it yo go
uh be on the lookout for that with your
IG my Ig is Janaya was here at Janaya
was here spell it out because people are
stupid
g-e-n-i-a-w-a-s-h- g-r-e boom appreciate
you pulling up thank you for having me
yep
fire hey we gotta wrap up an interview
brought to you by hardean Las Vegas
appreciate y'all watching hey don't
forget when you go to Vegas you got to
go to Hardee man it's the craziest
dispensary you'll ever walk into it
smells like [__] heaven in there all
right get in that Uber when you hit Sin
City tell them take me to hardine
they're gonna take you you're gonna get
a wild selection of the just top top of
the line cannabis the best selection
you'll go uh be able to see in the US
Plus on top of that they got the crazy
gear they got the clothes they got the
bikinis they got a wonderful selection
of Bud tenders that are very good at
their job man they'll take care of you
tell them that bootleg have sent you the
bud tenders are Harding don't know what
that means they're gonna get you hooked
up right all right go follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas or just go
check out their website too man
hardinglasvegas.com and when you're in
Vegas pull up to Jardin or you're
playing yourself for real